do you have kids or have you ever
observed a kid five or a six year old
kid speaking their language perfectly
uttering perfectly grammatical sentences
with perfect pitch and pronunciation and
the reason why these kids are so good
with your own native language is because
they learn in a brain fragment way they
absorb the patterns they don't learn
grammar rules they don't try to cram
information it just comes to them and
this is what this video is about I'm
going to show you a few simple tips to
make that happen as an adult so the
point I want to make is not that kids
are better at learning languages they're
simply acquire language while we try to
study language that makes a huge
difference and this is what this video
is about I'm going to show you a few
simple tips in order to acquire the
language in a brain friendly way and not
just studying or cramming and suffer etc
oh and one more thing just stay tuned
until the end of the video because apart
from the usual tips you are gonna get
one cool question and one cool tip when
I was reading the book by cut along with
very famous Hungarian polyglot a
sentence in particular struggling you
cannot learn language from grammar
but grammar from language that sentence
has a profound meaning of the way we
approach languages and for example if
you take a look at a five or six year
old kid they utter entire sentences and
grammatically correct entire sentences
of that and how do they do that if they
have never ever seen a grammar book on
the other hand adults try to learn and
try to cram grammar rules all the time
and they end up not even speaking the
language so there must be something
there either we do something bone or
kids do something or right and the
answer is as adults we have advantages
but we should also learn in a brain for
anyway
so remember learn the grammar from
language and not the other way around
so even that fundamental rule of thumb
of learning grammar from language you
might want to get compelling content
compelling material where you can find
real language conversations interactions
and then you can learn language and you
can extract patterns from that
compelling content you can sue by
grammar books if you want and keep them
as a reference but don't spend too much
time trying to understand grammar rules
and spending too much time on those
grammar books try to focus most of your
time on compelling content and learn
grammar as a consequence of that one of
the key features of compelling content
is grammar notes Reber notes and are
very useful in explaining the obscure
points that you find sometimes in text
when for example you tackle distant
languages that have obscure or very
difficult grammar at points but the
trick here is not to focus too much on
these grammar notes you want to go
through them understand the meaning and
then once you progress and move forward
in the language you will go back in time
and these grammar notes will be easily
understandable so don't spend too much
time on the grammar notes because
everything will be clearer and clearer
the more you move forward
[Music]
another cool thing that you can do is to
extract patterns from the compelling
content our brain is a machine as a
machine for figuring out patterns and
everything in life and obviously
language learning is no exception one of
the key things do you want to do in
order to internalize the grammar
patterns of of a new language is
actually to extrapolate extract patterns
from compelling content one cool way of
doing that is taking extracting a
sentence for example from a text and
then comparing the corresponding
structure in your own native language
our brain is a machine and it's a
machine that figures out patterns in
everything we do ranging from language
learning to motor skills sports so you
want to leverage that power of the brain
in order to extract patterns let me give
you an example let's suppose that I am
learning a time so let's suppose that I
stumble upon the sentence sumatra may
see king pero ling listen I've been
learning English for three months so the
underlying pattern is so not trained ACK
so as the plural of they are three may
see three months ke borrow that
conjunction in para I learn English and
in English the corresponding pattern is
subject have conjugated been and verb it
in I have been learning and then for an
expression of time and if you simply
take a piece of paper and compare the
two expressions you can then inform your
own parents you have I have been doing
this so not to miss again maybe you want
to say something like sort of a Mesa Cat
Cora so I've been running for two months
so by extracting the patterns that you
can simply change and modify the
elements and form new patterns and to
say whatever you want this is extremely
effective
and so now as promised I have one final
cool tip another cool trick that you can
do in order to refine and strengthen
your extrapolation of patterns so to
speak is to embed emotions into the end
to the process going back to the example
before is to get the example the pattern
that you have extrapolated and form your
own sentences sentences that are
personal to you let's suppose that you
really have started running in the park
nearby so maybe you learned a pattern
like I have been smoking for three for
three years and instead you want to say
I am been running for two months and you
say in Italian or you want to sit it in
another language so for every pattern
that you extrapolate form at least one
sentence that resonates with you that is
personal that has to do with something
that happened to you something you do
every day can be habits it can be people
it can be places the important thing is
that it's personal and it's a little bit
or at least a little bit emotional and
that makes a huge huge difference when
it comes to not only absorbing the
pattern but also reproduce it
[Music]
so the question goes like this what do
you do to learn grammar do you use
grammar books or you prefer language
learning material where you're going to
extract grammar patterns from please
share your strategies your techniques
and drop a comment in the section below
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]